okay is there any more food I need to
get something that my throat to fight
what is coming up you get the bar I'm
getting that nothing except for my baby
carrots have you heard of Blacula the
black dracula yeah well they have a
Jewish Dracula Oh what isn't it
Sydney Applebaum
[Applause]
can I talk to you for a second showing
up what's up sugar I'm going to put a
result for you in the front not in the
back the light and did you feel
threatened No
look at one of my worst Wednesday night
and how did the aliens return you all to
earth I was carried to gently
sorry I'm late gang on the chanson over
change is just nuts
I apologize I apologize
[Applause]
I'm just gonna grab a little coffee I
would never find any person in this room
except the cop Oh No except for come
bring the band he's oh he's useless he's
just that good to me so come go you
gotta go
this is all really so fascinating so do
you think that one of you could teach me
how to know there was a fly right near
your head took him out took him out yeah
yeah what this is a genuine Looney Toons
jacket I have a half-eaten taco in my
Tercel
[Applause]
[Applause]
them
oh and now I throw his hair into a tiny
little fire wasn't stranded it had
[Music]
[Laughter]
probably in the early stages of heat
stroke this place has everything
asbestos lupus the magazines at
Supercuts Dan quartet that'll be five
thousand dollars good day to you both
what the hell was that we misplace to
baby
[Applause]
my first thought you his swim oh yeah
frickin what
says nice to pet though
--kavitha
I put the cat down already at anything
you know if you're having such a bad and
maybe you should just go I love you and
nothing can change that
break your news Kevin
[Music]
[Music]